[Music]
I've always wanted to date the most
popular girl drive the nicest car and go
to the fanciest school Yale is the gold
correct more than anything in the world
but I can't afford any of that Michaels
paying me to escort my cousin who's
semi-formal I'll take your cousin what
I'll take your cousin to the dance why
what would you get out of it I get the
payment you were talking about and I get
to take your car you got a suit you're
getting paid to take a girl on a date
did you know that Michelle Obama got
paid to go on a date with Barack and
look how great that turned out is that
true I don't know but it could be true
and that is my point
[Music]
good evening let's do this so we can
stop doing this we don't care what you
say I happen to think that you and I can
have a really good time tonight he was
clearly never been to my high school
let's go shred some hardwood
[Music]
this is your job
no should be troubled rich girls and Eva
Schaffer it could be big business here I
figured out how to get the money I need
to go to Yale I'm offering my services
as a chaperone
from whatever it is that girls want hey
oh my god you didn't oh but I did every
day would be custom-built they could
pick my personality my interest whether
I'm a listener or a talker what's the
weirdest asfar I had listened to this
Girl Talk for four hours straight all I
was allowed to say was there is no other
way to see it oh my god that is the
perfect date there's no other way to see
it can you imagine if I get enough money
to get into Yale and date Shelby hey
it'd be my dream come true you're just
waiting for people to accept you instead
of accepting yourself you act so tough
it's just an F we used to spend time
together but I guess you'd have your new
rich Prince
[Music]
I don't know which version of myself I'm
supposed to be how she's a really bad
dancer yeah she's the worst I've been so
many people these past few months a
cowboy an art connoisseur and a bad
friend it's time to figure out who I am
and what I want what are some of your
interests outside of school
howdy usual teenage stuff
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you